what has happened to their citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for one piece 10
ultimate episode Aaron how are you I am incredible
my body is ready I am so ready to so is my head oh
that's a buggy reference ladies and gentlemen
you know what to do please go ahead and leave
a like on that video thank you so much to all have
been subscribed and clicking the notification Bell
because we got one more episode to get to and
today I wanted to give a shout out to the real
rejects new merch shop reject nationshop.com why
isn't Greg wearing one of those shirts because
like the professional planner is you forgot to
run the dryer so he's wearing this sweater right
now instead but look at these designs that we
have people are always asking what are some of
the best ways to support the channel one of the
best ways to support the channel is to get any
one of these random shirts and there's gonna
be more coming throughout the year and I got
my sister on board to become the head designer
it's gonna be like a family operation ladies and
gentlemen thank you guys so much you've already
bought yourself some teas you better get one soon
Buddy and lastly full interesting over there a
copy of One Piece patreon page let's get to it
I know Luffy made a deal with you to find
our long clown but if this is another one
of your tricks what are you gonna do
bleed on me because I said bleed on me
how do we know you're not
leading us to a trap I don't know
about your hits right come on I can sing
a nice sea shanty to pass the time oh
the neck is moving I bet that's an Easter
egg I just want to know if nami's okay
a beautiful talented woman does not choose
to allow herself with a pirate like our
long Army clearly needs to be rescued
that's right you saved that woman men
ah I like it I like the new one those oranges
they are oh my God oranges origin orange
oranges Origins actually it does not shut up
everyone shut up let's watch the show you're
ruining it for everyone I saw the vision
yeah yeah you saw what I was going for
a bunch of hippies blowing bubbles
in your orchard it's not an orchard
if it's oranges right I don't know okay
your orange farm NAMI it's your turn Nami
Nami is that nami's mommy Nami you're a vet oh she
had such a beautiful life before all this Darkness
oh the fish hop All In strike 10
high I don't know what that means
Queen's full no so it's just regular poker
okay I still don't know what it means
Richie we don't lie about money on this crew
I'll be back for the rest of your Berry later
is that the implication it's
what she does she's a thief
way to sync that up nice
that's interesting because you're so serious
in Stern but this is the dream that Luffy
keeps talking to her about yeah where did you
get the book Nami I took it from the bookstore
what it's not like I hurt anybody you
hurt the people you stole from I hate
eating tangerines every day I hate being poor
you have Bubbles and oranges no chica's not my
damn
or she had it coming I know it's 20 23 but this
was 20 years ago it would just be like hit that
kid I kept a plate on the stove for you I'm
not hungry classic parent move beat your ass
and come with kindness I got dinner ready
if you stop all that crying the day I found
my unit has
oh [__] raised by a fighter nice when I saw you
I knew I had to live I had to live so I could
take care of you she found purpose hey there's
some great parents in this show I love the
heart this show has I have another job for
you in the meantime one of the villages is late
with their true retainment which one Cocoa Village
no his job requires a human touch oh
arlong knows exactly what he's doing I
always wondered what happened to the infamous
red legs have captain of the cook Pirates yeah
when I was dies a fall ball in me and the only
thing under my command is this restaurant are
they gonna kill him off right now I hope
not a young pirate who was here recently
name of Luffy he's unlucky if I remember my
regulars oh you'll remember this one straw
hat stretchy did you choose Straw Hat goofy
base his name off of Luffy no he couldn't have
they do a really great job at knowing how to
gray out a lot of their environment but keep
our Central characters still colored
and saturated in their outfits oh yeah
it's impressive how they do that with
their designs our long did this please
please is that the same girl I think so yeah
black girl blue hair yeah not a lot of those
in this world hey they're all the same Aaron
don't be racist it's like she looks like her
Nami Nami Nami at the orange
Orchard if that's what it's called
I found NAMI so fast yeah that was really quick
Oh Sister beef also I haven't said it all
but Nami is cute as hell dude she's like
it was fine as [__] and you promised to
never steal again is that will force yeah
is that I think it is what the hell what the
Cameo like the only name actor in this thing
so far what's going on oh this is why she
hates Pirates oh my God shoot a duck she
was abducted oh or she chose to go with them
oh I'm gonna make a guess she is playing the
long game she actually wants to kill arlong
and his people over because it's like RR yeah
so he's strong
no no already damn he just got here no no
he's right here okay no I don't need any
part of your
system away they love you take the
rest of these clowns and sail away
from here I never want to see
you again you don't mean that
cry a little bit a little bit give me a tear
back to the boat before the fishermen find us
sail the hell out of here nah Luffy's persistent
I think she was very clear she wants us to leave
you don't know women they never say what they
mean the villagers are terrified of her not
all of them I'm a pirate Hunter we're here
to collect our lungs Bounty smart man yeah
turn around and leave now that's what I've been
saying hey let's start with nami seems you know
her very well she's a thief with no conscience
and when there's no more lift to take she leaves
and doesn't turn back you really think it's
a long game I feel like she just went down
the wrong path she doesn't like him and she
like he screwed over her town so she's gonna
be playing the long game you're not special
and I can't help you how about a meal what
Sanji with the charm huh oh no no no pretty good
oh yeah I have a feeling daddy Pirate's gonna die
already you think so I have to reunite
in episode 487. I took my choice
there's a new generation and they're coming up
Buns of impulsive children are ready to be enjoyed
you leave it too long it will go bad
a lot of deeper context to this
conversation just serve whiskey
okay maybe he's a I don't know because
you brought out the wine he's gonna die
I thought it was excited for a special
occasion like it's time to meet his I
feel like he's going I don't know his
last drink getting death Vibes yeah
love the Prosthetics on the fish
men yeah great job HP Lovecraft
uh uh what
it's like a subdivision of the
Marines this [__] has whiskers yeah
I have additional concerns how many
about twice as many as that let's double our usual
Arrangement that is where twice as many means yes
you know this is the best
thing I've eaten my entire life
better than a tangerine you really
need to know about Nami the truth is
what's going on is it like a
Thanos and Gamora situation
is that what you're getting at I can
see that yeah that makes some sense
well you think she's nebula who's the blue hair
yeah in a way Jimmy does a hundred thousand very
adult you got the bucket hat in the chain
that's hilarious take it that's all I got
three plates on the table ah damn it I have
two daughters you'll have to pay for the 50
000 Berry each he gave you everything I had too
bad for you it ain't enough no that is [__] up
oh it's a family reunion
because you are my daughters and
I would never deny that wow she
probably hates her because she she
said something no no no no no no
oh man I love you girls
foreign I think you're right
oh man wait nami's working for the
pirate that killed your mother oh God
gorgeous shot I was just thinking the same thing
best Dynamic on the show these two she made her
choice I ended up hearing about Nami from other
people she told you to leave Luffy so did you hmm
how do you know she's not one of our Long's
crew same way I knew you weren't going to kill
me when I cut you down from that cross same way
I knew about usop Luffy can see people for their
potential and who they can really be I know Nami
is good to know it too yeah I don't think exactly
a long con I think she feels like included a
lot of guilt oh yeah my mom's dead because of me
this is like her punishment she's serving
her pendants I hope it's a long cone she's
got to get revenge for her mama it's not too
easy keeping Marine patrols out of the area
and with your increase in activity I guess
it's just the price of doing business you're
not smarter than people give you credit for
you shouldn't have said that man shouldn't
have said that don't discriminate does
it surprise you that I have intelligence
enslave my people slavery has been
abolished what's your Prejudice for
me who have all the same rights as humans silly
anything intentionally cast a black guy no
I can accept the terms of our usual deal
give it all back
you're smarter than people who gives
you credit for kill them kill them
anyway and what about our deal what
about it I have the money a hundred
million Berry I thought that money fair
and square now are you ready to honor
our agreement wow that's a lot of berry U.S
dollar translation that's like 200 dollars
that's why our USA is number one baby
maybe there's a way for the rat to earn some
extra Berry after all what are you doing
buying you a drink you can't we're on Judy
oh come on God why don't you just shave his
hair it is so awful just commit man just
shave it off your head looks like a penis
aren't you full of surprises
dude you're gonna confess maybe the straw
hat Pirates aren't the villains that the
Marines are making them out to be you
know something 's Luffy's grandfather
would you why would you why would you say that
tell anyone he's gonna tell everyone they say
what you want about Lucy but it's the real
deal it doesn't matter not to a man like Garb
you color Outside the Lines you get your arm
chopped off it's a little extreme if you ask
me must have been hard going off with the dad
like accent Morgan I am nothing like that straw
hat filler with a straw hat came through here
the other day they have to change your heart
come on peace head last thing I want to do is
put myself in the middle of a family dispute
it's special reminds me of another pirate
we knew back in our Glory Days you're not
saying it's going to make it less true um
the kid reminds me of gold Roger is that
the guy who had the the one piece yeah is he
related Luffy I still only bought a coat sir
thank you for the meal you see he's not gonna kill
him have the Navigator said a course immediately
for the Konomi Islands you have to
know when it's time to let him go
change is coming whether you want it or
not it's their turn now just turn around
okay he's safe told you it would have
been satisfying if he died right here
maybe Luffy's the son of him and
then he that's nothing he's not
really the grandson of our villain
oh you think he just like took him
all took him in after yeah maybe he just
took him as a baby or something that
could be interesting Theory okay could be an
interesting Theory it isn't interesting here
now grave too oh oh no no
no no no there's important
stuff in there it's not what you think you have no
oh and you're hiding it next to her
mother's body mommy what kind of monster
her for her mother's mother's death unless
some other thing happens in this flashback
which we're about to find out I need to speak
with you and who are you my name is Nami
prepare to die you wanna kill me
little girl no I want to join your crew
say what
whoops I have something you want
because she's got a black guy fetish
I killed your mother to come work for me how can
you trust a human like that why would you do that
because you have something I want told
arlong I'd work for him on one condition
that he let me buy back Cocoa Village
that would take a lifetime I have the money
and now I can buy the freedom of the village
and everyone in it why'd you have to have
everyone hate you she can let the secret
get out well I couldn't lose you too or
anyone else oh that's really sad yeah
so you kept that secret oh the
easiest and you let me hate you
I'd want the crowd
I want people to know how good of a
person I am I've heard the Pirates are
stashing their plunder in this area you two
wouldn't know anything about that would you
oh Luffy Zorro Sanji and I guess who's up get
some ass I guess it's mine 100 million Berry
how did you know how long
put you up to this didn't he
watch yourself or we'll take
you into custody as well oh
somebody do something oh I hate this I hate this
so much you Draconian [__] damn it's so messed
up dude I'm really invested in everyone's personal
motives yeah yes let me go they can't do this
Let Me Wait get back that money ask your
friends for help if they were so close
to she was already at the 100 million marks
you should have clued in the straw hat team
she's already used to keeping things
so close to the chest she doesn't
trust people anymore I'm just saying
you know I mean I agree with you the
girl can't trust now the time has come to
restore the natural order of this world
oh this is so sad yeah
man all right just rage will burn
through Cocoa Village we will
teach each and every human their rightful
place beneath us you tell them fish needo
ask your friends for help
sad
I'm tattooed on your body dude
oh
I was gonna help you
I love this show man
so good I told you to get the hell out of here
you did you don't know anything
about what's going on here I don't
oh
of course I will damn what a great scene
oh hell yeah oh man God I
love this God I love this show
that's right
damn look at this is a [__] live action anime
oh man what's that
they're attacking the village uh-oh
no
ah
of course of course that's where it ends
can't wait for all five of them to be on
the same screen together all right all right
I got one more episode to go through so just
talk about the super quick Aaron take it away oh
man this episode's incredible this episode was
incredible from the the themes of of family
you know the themes of protection going on
um yeah man this episode was great from start
to finish like getting to see nami's backstory
finally after not really knowing what her
deal was the entire time to realizing how
um full of heart and full of uh selflessness
she was under the guise of being selfish and
pushing the people that she loves away whether it
be her sister whether it be the straw hat crew and
yeah seeing the the lengths people will go to for
family I thought that was was really inspiring and
and really really meant a lot uh yeah I just think
that this movie wasn't this episode wasn't uh high
in action as we've come to to see over the course
of the show but just seeing that has the heart
has the um I don't understand the emotionality of
it that scene we just watched was incredible like
Nami going into like trying to find her um I
don't know well she lost everything but yeah
then her finally accepting their help and then
just seeing how Luffy was able to be there for
her and believe in her like the fact that Luffy
is someone who just believes in people to such
a degree sees people and sees things in people
that they don't see in themselves is incredible
and I think this is the first episode of the show
we've seen Luffy not have this overwhelming like
um not not necessarily optimism but like this
gung-ho attitude he's very much like kind of
somber very serious for most of this episode and I
think for a character who is very much like upbeat
for all the time I think it's important to have
those notes have those accents for the character
to really make them feel more human because I
think you could easily with an adaptation run
the risk of a character feeling like a cartoon
but rather This Crew and Luffy and themselves
feels very dynamic as a leader as a character
and yeah and just watching these different people
come together has just been very satisfying of a
journey and yeah really this episode really got
me emotional uh towards the end you know seeing
what nami's gone through seeing like love through
the face of of rejection via fear and yeah just I
loved it man like didn't it didn't need the action
for me you know it had the character and then
also with uh with sanji's like surrogate father
and him like in the role that he was playing
in here just all of it really came together
and nami's Mom you know like her standing up for
uh for her chosen family just all of it really
really was impactful and yeah yeah it's
penultimate episode and uh yeah I would be
if this is a week to week show like Aaron I'd
be so frustrated that it just ended right now
because I'm so excited to see them all finally
come together and accept each other as a unit
yeah this was uh this is great yeah man what'd
you think yeah I think you're you're right about
that I think thematically they were showing
the uh The Duality between like the types of
surrogate parents and types of parenting that
we have one side is like very misguided kind of
parenting or straight up villainous parenting
with our long the evil captain guy um even you
call him penis head even with even with his dad
that parenting side and then of course you got
um uh oh my God sorry it's been a day Nema I'm
already I've just like flaking on everyone's name
at the moment I've just lost the whole episode
about her oh the uh nami's bomb Navi God damn
it yeah as I can see the letters I was like
what the hell is wrong with my brain right now
um Nami and her her parents and and then of
course Sanji as well and looking at like Again
The Duality between those types of parenting
and how that affected them too I thought was
beautifully thematically displayed here in this
episode and I think we've been watching how these
children have grown up into adults and how that's
affected them you're even sort of watching over
the course of Luffy from where he was to how he is
in this episode you're watching him go from being
a boy into a man and then it still manages to give
you that reward and cathartic line that you could
only pull off like lines like what when he's when
he like puts his hands up in the air like I could
just imagine it in Japanese with the subtitles
where he's he's exclaiming of course I will and
99 of the time that would not work you know and
you I would see something like a moment like
that in an anime if you're like well that wouldn't
translate well to the lot to like live action that
wouldn't translate well and then somehow this show
manages to pull off some [__] like that where
you're like that's great that's cool you know like
they I think it says they earn those moments they
really do even even amid such a serious moment
because they did such a great job of showing Luffy
through the goofy sides to give him a serious
moment to then watch that be um this embellishment
of all these other qualities all it's like this
is this beautiful burrito of like seriousness
and childlike Wonder All in One and it's just one
of course I will moment that I thought was great
and the actress plays on me I thought is uh her
performance has been very consistent it's quite
excellent here yeah and I love that this show has
let us know everyone's motivation has let us know
because everyone's usually set up with some type
of mystery and then sometimes a show will stretch
that [__] out until like season two or three
if we're talking just even live active shirt and
Anime it like goes on for a much longer time
right but in live action they'll stretch that
out for what feels like [__] forever and then
here I love that we actually got it and we now
know everyone's backstory and we see that this
Suicide Squad of sorts uh some kind of Suicide
Squad yeah of how they are a fan of how they can
they can be a family yeah because they don't have
they don't have family anymore and you know it's
like Nami has family and stuff but you could see
how them setting on all these and I like how
they all have like different conquests that
they're after these different Adventures after
and uh while I while I do like I I enjoy our
long uh I enjoy the design of the fish people and
stuff and I I enjoy the commentary that they make
and I like how nuanced it is I really like how
nuanced it is yeah where he's not just a guy who
terrorizes and that there is at the end of the
day a lot of well racism until I dealt his way
or what would you call fishism humanism yeah some
type of some discrimination xenophobia uh type of
thing Eric yeah yeah there's there at the end of
the day there's um a lot of systematic injustices
that have been dealt his way that have formed him
has formed him to be the the rage the wrathful
man that he is and at the end of the day still is
like still a villain yeah I I like uh I like the
layers a lot to him and I can't quite pinpoint
it yet and I wonder if it's because the show has
introduced us to other villains who I've just
thought have been more engaging and ultimately
scary like when there's someone like mihawk
out there yeah I'm not as scared of an AR long
because I'm like I feel like a Miha could easily
kill this guy when when they're talking so you
know what it is actually I think it's it might
be because our log was in like one episode
and then like for a little bit and then he came
into last episode and was like more predominant
and mihawk was only one episode two right but
it's presence no I'm not uh no I'm saying no
I'm thinking of a different point here is
that why this this thing about our long and
I guess they're kind of sitting like he's like the
main there's a lot of villains yeah you know right
now there's there's a lot of villains and I could
and I think it's one of the joys of a of a series
is you can have ultimate villains especially the
anime where you can have multiple villains and
stuff and uh I think that I don't quite know
what it is yet maybe I'll maybe I'll wait on
that thought I'm gonna I'm gonna rest on that
thought before we get to the fine until we watch
the final episode because I'm like is there too
many villains yeah uh because like mihawk seems
like he's a personal villain for Zorro for Zorro
and he's not really like a villain you know and
then you have the captain who's more for like
yeah he's hungry the Pirates in general but
he's more for Luffy and then actually no now I
think about it yeah every every villain seems
to have one that's like okay but yes our long is
threatening to take over all of humanity and to
like you know rule at all but he's mainly here to
serve for Nami yeah you know and then Usopp had
the butler that's been dealt with yeah you know um
so he didn't die though right no he didn't no no
he was he was uh rowing away yeah yeah uh yeah I
think like with the way they've been I guess the
way this episode treated our long I felt like our
long should have been in the show longer or built
him up longer yeah especially when there's such
a diabolicalness to the the way it's all coming
across and such like a huge thing like they're
now gonna say like he's got the map he's gonna
set sail and take over I'm like oh I feel like
there should have been maybe more of a build up
to it yeah but I don't know like I really don't
know yet yeah I think I said like I can't remember
which episode it was because we kind of like
watched these like in in pairs but it was
I think I said that like yeah that would come
the final finale would come down to um our long
and uh and GARP being like the two coming to
head or like two people we'd be facing in the
finale episode and yeah I don't think I don't
necessarily think GARP is super threatening but
I think that they serve our characters well as far
as like what they mean for them and I think that
mihawk was both cool and serves for um for Zorro
now could he have been in the episodes more I do
agree you know maybe like build up to this threat
that he's supposed to represent uh I do think that
they've you they've utilized him well in the
time that we've we've seen him and I think he's
the only one so far that like I I get where
he's coming from but he has like that thing
that makes him corrupt you know like oh like I
understand why you feel the way you do but like
you're taking it like too far like you took it
like a a direction that like kind of get where
I can't align with you you know like like like
a killmonger like a Magneto you know and well
I feel like the dialogue provides that but I kind
of feel like the performance misses some of that
Nuance I think it's because of the Prosthetics
I was literally as I was saying that I was
wondering if that might be it because because
he at the end of the day he does just play it
like Overlord at least the way it translates he's
just he's just a bet he's just villainy and and
when clearly there's like through the dialogue
I'm like well it sounds like this guy's really
there's a lot of hurt and suffering this guy's
been dealt with dealing with you but he it's kind
of plays it feels like the perf the performance
feels a little bit one note to me okay when the
dialogue and the context feels deeper than that
note yeah I think like the the this place is
Sinister you know yeah no I can agree with that
I think the the times we've seen him like talk
about the the plights of being a fish person and
like the emotional weight of of that has not been
um I don't know if congruence the right word
but to the same level as his level of villainy
or like yeah or the level of Engagement we've
seen him like there there hasn't been anything
that has made him overtly threatening or like oh
like we got it we gotta take this guy down in the
in the same way that we've um it just seems like
everywhere he goes he's murdering left and right
yeah yeah we could we could use more you know
and I I do I can definitely agree with that fact
um yeah I look I will say that being said I
look forward to having Nami get her revenge
on this guy yeah yeah what he's doing to the town
for what he did to the mother you know yeah and
I don't think it's a satisfying villain for our
crew but more so specifically for her and I feel
like all of the villains to an extent have been
like I mean satisfying for individual Heroes to
take down except for usab doesn't really you
know suffer Luffy you know get his rematch get
his rematch too you're right there there's
a person element for him there as well yeah
um we'll see I don't know like I'd rather
wait till the final episode for actually
casting a final judgment about it fair okay
um yeah I like the sister too she was a good
performer she was good um alrighty well one
more to go we'll see how it goes alrighty
excited for it thank you guys for being
here and we'll see you for the finale bye